the parents of a missing Colorado mother
are revealing a possible motive for
their daughter's murder new court
documents filed in a lawsuit against
Patrick Frazee allege he killed Kathy
Bharath over a custody dispute
Bharath disappeared nearly three months
ago and Frazee is charged with her
murder
Jamie yuccas is in Los Angeles with the
latest developments Jamie good morning
good morning were likely to learn more
in the criminal case against Patrick
Frazee during a preliminary hearing
scheduled for tomorrow in the meantime
an update to a civil wrongful death suit
filed by Kelsey Vera's parents against
Frazee reveals what they believe
happened to their daughter Kelsey Vera's
parents claim Patrick Frazee had motive
to kill Bharath because she refused to
give him custody of their one-year-old
daughter the new allegation is part of a
civil complaint filed by Baris parents
they're suing Frazee for emotional
distress following a series of false
statements he allegedly made to Kelsey's
mother cheryl over the phone on December
2nd including that he and Kelsey broke
up on or about Thanksgiving Day and
agreed at a Cracker Barrel restaurant in
Colorado Springs to split custody of
their daughter when Cheryl pressed
Frazee for details about her daughter's
whereabouts he apparently suggested that
Kelsey may have flown somewhere with a
friend or coworker typically if Kelsey
was going to travel we knew ahead of
time we spoke with Cheryl Bharath in
December she says she talked to Kelsey
on the phone Thanksgiving morning
shortly before the 29 year old went
shopping at a Colorado supermarket where
she was last seen on this surveillance
video with her daughter the lawsuit
alleges Frazee told Cheryl a series of
lies knowing that Kelsey was dead
because he had killed her or caused her
to be killed I think he's a very
dangerous person
Michele Stein says her close friend
crystal Lee confided in her about her
role in covering up Kelsey Barriss death
earlier this month Lee pleaded guilty to
tampering with evidence for allegedly
helping Frazee get rid of Barris cell
phone I think he is a true narcissist
he's a master manipulator
he probably manipulates every single
person that comes in contact with him
because he thinks he can Barriss parents
are suing Frazee for an unspecified
amount and have been granted temporary
custody of their one year old
granddaughter Frazee's attorneys have
filed a motion to dismiss the civil suit
claiming Beres parents do not have the
right to sue him gale
terrible story thank you very much Jamie